yo what is up everybody this procedure
man Luigi here with another Borderlands
the pre-sequel video today I'm gonna be
showing you my nice build and kind of
how to build it I'm gonna show you all
the skill trees that I put points into
and kind of the weapons I use a class
mod I use the shield a journal using
kind of all that stuff so I hope you
enjoy and we'll hop right into it so
first thing we're gonna go over can some
general gear
this is gonna be centered around the
celestial law bring your class mod there
are other class mods that you can build
your skills around but this is the most
general and I think just like it's the
best general class mod so I'm going to
be using that I use a normal turtle
shield
I just love turtles fields the most if I
get a really good other shield I might
use it but for now I'm sticking with the
just general good turtle shield I vary
from grenades I usually use a quasar
quasar or the bonus package I use what I
believe to be the best class mod not
class mod sorry
oz kit in the game the 3d d1 dot e I
think it is a really great around oz kit
especially because it sometimes
regenerates your fields now the weapons
I will usually use my a Bowie Maggie or
Rustler striker both legendary weapons
I'll use the resolute oh sorry I'll use
a TMP a corrosive TMP against Felicity
and rk5 that's what I keep around for
and I also use a the thorny ol Rosie
it's a fire one and they ionizing
Polaris beam it's like the Moxie's
weapon except it doesn't heal you but I
think it does a lot more damage so
that's why I use it so I primarily use
these for guns these for guns this gear
so let's hop into the skill points now
you see the these are my skill trees
don't worry I'm gonna look at all of
them a lot more later on I'm gonna show
you uh image images of all of them
completed at the end of this video but
for now I'm gonna reset all my skills
and I'm gonna go through each one that I
use why I use it and so hopefully you'll
want to use it too so we're over here
we're gonna hit reset skillpoints yup
alright our CEO points have been reset
we have 48 bees not get any steel points
for level 1 and level 2 so start out get
showdown now I want to start with this
always put 1 in order
since order is just an all-around good
perk it only cost 1 and just to make
sure you don't waste this one perk slot
now there is some boost you get in
wanted and law if from the class mod
however I do not use anything other than
order in this law and order tree I think
this is used for melee builds however I
will not be building any form of melee
with this initial build so we're gonna
hop on over to the main tree the fan of
hammer
so start ruthless which is extending the
duration of showdown always hundred
percent all the way definitely I also
always do full in my magnificent six
since if any non elemental weapon do you
the last six boats do extra damage which
is really good for shotguns and pistols
with not super high capacities like the
Maggie I also always put some stuff in
courage and saddle up or I usually do
it's not as much of a must as ruthless
but I still definitely do it end the
class mod does give me more bottled
courage and I do really like saddle up
so I'm gonna start by putting at least
three in bottled courage and two and
saddle up just to get a little a little
bit in there and we'll go back to that
once we are fine a fine tuning all the
rest of it so we're gonna get a 1 in
short-fused
since it after killing the enemy all
your shots of deal explosive damage for
a short time that's bonus as a 35% of
your gun damage is all is a dish added
on to your normal gun damage as
explosive damage I think it's really
great especially for one point the
marginal benefits that you get from
using this one point in here so say I
put one point in short fuse I get a lot
more out of that than I do from putting
just one extra point in bottle courage
so I'm gonna put that in short fuse I am
also so pickpocket which is reloading
gun
slinger which has to do with reloading
and hell's coming with me which has to
do with reloading I don't really care
for any of these skills especially
pickpocket don't like that I never mail
a gunslinger I've really never used if
any of them I'll use hell's coming with
me since it gives me the chance to fire
twice but I still really don't care for
it I do care for faster than you and
high noon high noon gives you bonus
damage the longer you're in cool that in
showdown and faster in you gives you
additional reload speed weapon swap
speed and fire rates after killing
someone really don't care about the
weapons while speed that however the
reload speed and the fire rate most of
all is what I like so I'm gonna put two
in there I'm gonna put two and high noon
and let's throw one more involved
courage it's probably gonna be it for
about courage and then we get one for
each of you which lets me use two
pistols if I if I have one pistol I have
my other hand gets a piss as well so we
might come back to this tree maybe tad
one or two in to saddle up faster than
you and I nude but we're gonna make sure
that we get everything we want so we're
gonna head over to the rifle one now the
class mod gives you plus a bonafide grit
and plus quick shot
I think bonafide grit you're fine with
just putting one point in there I would
like I you'd like to use the other first
like I kind of five set of points in
snap shot since I do shoot a lot from
the hip and dramatically increased
accuracy and recoil reduction from the
hip is pretty great so we're gonna put
four in that and one in bonafide grit so
bonafide grit we get the regeneration of
your max health really I don't care too
much about but the critical hit damage
if you kill someone you get bonus
crooked damage that's pretty great so
I'm gonna do that now here Unchained and
quick shot I really like both of these
quick shot after you reload you get gun
damage and fire rate increase from the
hip as I said I shoot a lot from the hip
and because of the class mug you get a
ton of gun damage fire rate so I am
going to I'm gonna put a few in here and
I'm gonna max out one change now
Unchained is when you shoot an enemy you
get a fire rate increase and you get a
stack of it and you can get a one stack
every second if you don't shoot anybody
for 10 seconds you lose the stacks and
the fire rate is 5% per stack and 21
stacks so you can get a 105 percent
faster increased fire rate from this
unchained skill so I think it's really
great use it Fistful of bullets
increases your magazine with all gun
types by three this is really good for
low Matic shotguns like I have the
Rustler striker and it's only has two
shots normally but because this has
three and it only takes one bullet per
shot so I get five shots instead of two
that is an over 100 percent increase in
the magazine size really great
definitely put someone into it and also
it's only one it's only one point so
it's pretty good next crack shot I
always use crack shot the first shot of
a fully loaded magazine causes bonus
damage and it can cause an explosion if
you kill them with that first shot I get
a lot of first shot kills especially
with head shots from pistols snipers and
just any you most shots with a shotgun
so I'm gonna I'm gonna fill that up five
but we're going all in for that now
trick shot is alright you bulleted stuff
and they bounce back and kill people I
think it's like using a shotgun with a
lot of bullets you'll definitely get a
lot of bullets that bounce back but
honestly I don't it's more of a novelty
for me than anything else so I'm not
gonna put anything into that I'm not
gonna put anything to impatience you get
reload speed increase however I don't
I'm not too big on the reload speed like
over here you can see faster than you if
I go back over here fast when you
doesn't give you reload speed and that
is that I like a better than weapon swap
speed but the biggest part of faster
than you is fire rate I like to fire
rate a lot more than I like to reload
speed so I reload speed
cool and all but I don't think it's
worth that point hot lead and tombstone
if I were to put anything in I put
something tombstone so I get some more
critical chance more critical transit as
the critical chance here you get
critical chance damage from bonafide
grit and critical uh credit so critical
damage from bona fide grit sorry and
critical chance from tombstone it's
alright you can kind of swap in and out
from this this is where I get to the
point where I'm kind of just adding to
what I have rather than investing new
skills however new skills might like the
might be better but in my build which
has been very good I can kill any boss
in the game relatively quickly I'm gonna
stay
what I got so I'm gonna put two more in
quick shot that will unlock Unforgiven
all shots have a chance to ricochet
towards other nearby enemies dealing 10%
of damage per hit also show that ending
triggers an explosion on all enemies who
have been shot by you now the first part
of this I honestly forgot since it
doesn't affect me too much or I don't
think it affects too much but the
explosion is a good amount of damage and
it's nice like if you bear almost kill
gun showdown he's dead when showdown
ends so we're gonna get that one and
Unforgiven now we have two skill points
left I feel pretty good about this tree
I'm gonna head back and I'm gonna
usually put one in saddle up faster on
you and high noon I'm gonna put one in
two of those trees let's see uh high
noon
yeah let's say I didn't I didn't get the
this reload speed so I'm gonna put one
fast in you a little little make up for
it and probably saddle up I like saddle
up more than I like High Noon set up
effects all the time any time get it
killed and there you go we use all 50
points 50 points sorry 50 minus two boys
48 points girls we used all 48 eight
points it's a pretty good I think it's
pretty good setup especially with the
guns I use I use the Maggie's and the
striker shotgun plus the Rosie and the
other electric laser with continuous
damage and it works really well I killed
top I can kill the Sentinels so quickly
it's crazy
once those lasers start getting their
continuous damage and the striker kills
most normal infantry mobs like scabs and
stuff just a ton of times with one shot
or one or two shots so that's gonna be
basically it for this video I do hope
you have enjoyed hope you guys enjoyed
this little a semi quick look into what
my build is for Nisha
it is a very good it's [ __ ] lawbreaker
build I think it does really well I hope
you guys can get the celestial blob
bringer class mod I got I've seen it
twice in vending machines however I also
think it can drop from the Sentinel
how do you believe I could be mistaken
on that but I'm pretty sure he drops it
if not you can farm some vending
machines I do either have a vending
machine video up or I'm gonna put it up
so that the best way to farm vending
machines so make sure you see all that
keep looking at my channel for more of
this content and that is about it I'm
gonna keep let's see I'm gonna keep all
right so all here is up you can see a
long order I'm gonna just show you all
my class skills that I'm gonna call it
at it so law and order just the one just
just the one in order next and fan of
the hammer yeah this I'm not gonna go
through every single one but you can see
all the points and additional points
from the class mod that you get in each
of these skills that I use so it's about
it and then I put I think I put the most
in rightful woman if I am correct and
yeah so that's about it hope you guys
have enjoyed this video if you did make
sure you keep checking out my channel
for more Borderlands the pre-sequel
content and legendre's no legendaries
and we call I'm calling it a day peace
out guys